your next comedian um
he's hans kim you might
know him from kill tony uh
okay tom's kid
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
i think she's hot too whoever said that
great observation uh you guys are very
keen
uh i am asian so please shout that out
anytime you can
excuse me have someone kick this guy out
just heckled me
i mean i love stand up comedy but
sometimes i don't try as a painter
because i've never been painting a
picture and the canvas be like blue
that doesn't look like a tree you should
kill yourself
draw something asian
good to be here being an artist
i i was on a show and this guy comes up
to me he's like dude a bunch of kids
walked in you can't say any swear words
today which i think is like so
disrespectful to my [ __ ] art form
it's like going out to a musician and
being like hey a bunch of polish dudes
walked in you can't use any g-sharps
these are my tools
good to be here in texas i'm uh loving
the south because i'm also a southerner
from south korea
[Applause]
one of you guys yeah
[Applause]
there's only two things i like shooting
commies and k-pop
[Applause]
uh i love rednecks there's so many
rednecks in texas there's the [ __ ]
best to party with and they're also
they're also great because they can
survive in any wilderness situation that
you put them in
except a situation where everyone has
evil rights
what kind of [ __ ] them up
they can live in a swamp with an
alligator why can't you live in a
cul-de-sac with a minority
[Applause]
figured
[Applause]
you try out
[Music]
i uh i get made fun of a lot because i
look like this and
no one respects minorities
you know my friend's like dude you got
such an asian smile
like thanks now i get to think about how
i'm physically different from everyone
around me
every time i feel happiness
[Applause]
my asian friends make fun of me they're
like dude uh if not like general says
chicken they're like dude general says
chicken is just a shitty americanized
version of something authentically asian
like yeah but so am i
[Applause]
my favorite movie is rush hour 3.
[Applause]
love
love america i don't understand all the
sayings in america they say prison don't
drop the soap
it should be don't pick up the self
you can drop as much self as you want
it's the bending over when they really
get you
even if you don't drop the soap you're
still gonna get raped
you're just gonna really clean hands
while it happens
who are these rapists like man i want to
get that kid but he never drops a soap
doesn't have a butthole we'll never know
rapists don't like that they're
go-getters they don't take no for an
answer
[Applause]
but uh i am single i have uh yet to meet
my soul mate i begin to think maybe it's
her fault she needs to get out more
she seems like a loser
i think i can do better
my friend's like dude you need to learn
how to talk to women
maybe or maybe women should learn how to
listen to
odds why don't you want to hear about
the federal reserve
i want to party relax
uh this little girl was like did you
know that my vagina can make a baby so
my vagina is a 3d printer
okay actually your womb is a 3d printer
your vagina is a tray
it only prints one thing with lots of
errors
it takes nine months to print
and the whole time it's printing it's
complaining
needless to say i did not say any trades
that night
i don't think i could ever [ __ ] a dude
i've never looked at a beautiful woman
i've been like wow is there a version of
her that's bigger and hairier has less
kindness
i'll put that in my butthole
[Applause]
straight as [ __ ]
please believe me my dad doesn't
my dad's like why would you want to be
gay if you're gay that means most of the
gender you're attracted to isn't
attracted to you back and i was like
whoa can't even imagine
let's cry a lot
um but uh do you love the ladies
a lot of ladies they call me a premature
ejaculator which hurts my feelings
it's like premature to who
i came right at the perfect time and i
felt amazing
it takes maturity now to please yourself
lady
i'm glad that women give birth i feel
like a man gave birth would be like bro
i've been eating so much protein and
creatine during my pregnancy
this baby's like 27 pounds already bro
check out his triceps and the ultrasound
it's all about those gains in the first
trimester
i don't like asian women that much
because they act like they're hotter
than asian men but we look exactly the
same [ __ ]
[Applause]
i look like you
i could throw on a wig and be a seven
why are you bragging that you can
[ __ ] white dudes i can phone white
dudes
you can all fun white
the
dudes
people to [ __ ]
i mean how do you think asian women are
even created in the first place
me [ __ ]
i'm a crucial part of the sexy process
please stop trying to skip
if you have sex with me our children
will be very beautiful
[Laughter]
and then half will be great engineers
and that's important too
people make fun of asians because we
like to eat dogs which i understand can
be very shocking because in america dogs
are treated like family members but in
asia we treat our family members like
family members
it's this real little tradition we have
back home
instead of buying an animal we love our
grandma
[Applause]
treat everyone better in asia unless
you're a baby girl in case you throw you
in the river
don't look in the
how fast our river go
i love being asian because i can walk
into a starbucks and then tell them that
my name is ching chong bing bong the
third
what are they going to say that's not
your name
excuse me i come from a long line of big
bombs
whenever someone is racist to me i'm
like oh you hate respectful people who
keep to themselves
okay good luck finding an affordable car
i'm trying to lay hard
i i'm not a racist i'm a minority how
could i be impossible
i uh i was uh walking along the street
and this guy comes up to me he's like
chubby bunny
it's like dude just cause i look like
this doesn't mean i speak your
ching-chong language
[Applause]
don't be racist and the post office is
right there
class were too small
uh i saw a dude on an airplane reading a
book in arabic which kind of freaked me
out
but then i saw him fold the corner of
the page and put the book away and i was
like oh thank god he's got future blanks
[Applause]
my favorite marvel movie is the black
panther movie that's how little racism i
have
i think the black panther movie was
great because it gave black children a
hero they could finally look up to
and not just someone like martha king jr
malcolm x or harriet tubman or thurgood
marshall and george
[Applause]
now there's a fake person that dresses
like a cat
when they're going to come out with our
movie the yellow panda
[Applause]
i recognize
um
i i used to date this girl who was
really into yoga and choke sex
i was like do you enjoy breathing or not
i could remind you millennials
my uh my sister just got back from a
mission trip if you don't know that
that's where americans go to third world
countries to get new profile pictures
she's like you know your toilet water is
cleaner than the drinking water in
africa
like how's that my fault it's got pipes
you know
cut this [ __ ] in
if i see an african walking down the
street i'll let him drink from my toilet
it's not a problem
just flush afterwards
[Applause]
splashback
uh i was talking to my friend and he was
like dude the only reason black people
are making stronger than white people is
because we bred them as slaves to be
that way
i was like oh
that that's how it happened though why
don't you guys do that to yourselves as
well then you know
yourselves big and strong instead of
giving a superpower to people who hate
you
why are you [ __ ] your cousin
i'm exactly the move of a genetic
scientist
but uh yeah it's uh great to uh
be telling jokes right now uh i'm very
gender fluid i'm biologically male but
my bullies identify me as a [ __ ]
[Applause]
i do not consent to this gender
my uh my friends are like dude you're
book smart but i'm street smart
i'm like oh you're smart in a way that's
all measurable or comparable
how convenient for you
maybe you're dumb and you're insecure
about it that's why you committed
aggravated assault
it's called crime stop punching me it
hurts
all right that was my time thank you
guys very much
[Applause]